by the way Jimmy you made a point of
going on the Emmys and making the point
that the Emmys need a host I agree with
you yes yeah yeah all these shows need
to hold it was it was like a lost show
they were lost all the time yeah nobody
was directing anything they need a host
even just for in case something happens
somebody has to
who's designated to go up and say
something cuz these are live shows them
things do happen at the end of the
Oscars they screwed the whole thing up
and I you know I'm like I guess I have
to go up there but I don't know it's
week one of my favorite moments in any
like going back all the way the Academy
Awards when like Johnny Carson or Bob
Hope would or Billy Crystal who was a
great the Academy Awards if something
cool happened on stage or something
funny somebody would come back and say
hey yes you know what let's let's talk
about what just happened there was none
of that and I do think a host is
required of course of course if you have
a good host that makes it fun yeah
you've hosted those shows yeah and you
know what that is you you sit back there
you wait to see what happens and then
you come out and comment on well there
is it's true that the shows are too long
and also now there's not that drama
anymore of who's gonna win because you
find out immediately on your phone but
it to me that it's more of a case made
for a host because like okay there's not
the suspense that there was and maybe
there aren't the big movies aren't
necessarily getting nominator but
there's not that like oh my god who's
going to win feeling so you might as
well make it funny and make it fun